so I mean hi Phil you mean you'll miss
me like on a bit of a high right now I
am on uh I am like ah ah yes I mean I
was incredible like it's like it
happened so fast I mean it's a camellia
quite a two hour show
I'm change and it felt like ten minutes
I don't know I think that's that's a
good sign
yeah the crowd is unbelievable I mean
they're there right there and you're
right there in it and I had a great time
yeah yeah
so I mean after the success of crazy I
mean crazy with Asians is still like
number one domestic like it's big
numbers so as your phone isn't blowing
up all the time now no no I think the
last person that called me was my
grandma FaceTime called me earlier I was
like I'm trying to look for the award
show but I can't find it I'm like it's
in can't forget it you know you know I
kind of like yeah but no and now my vote
hasn't blowing up but I'm wearing a big
whatsapp group though crazy search
agents Kass and we're just we're a light
with with happiness beautiful yeah I'd
heard you say something like how your
parents don't usually like the things
that you do so I mean how do they feel
about the phone my my dad I don't think
it seen it yet I mean I'm mad at him for
that yes take your girlfriend go see it
my grandma saw it doesn't doesn't like
my wake she really doesn't like wig okay
and then she was like you weren't in it
a lot and you're not any kid not acting
and I was like oh my god thank you
grandma thank you for the merry
validation thank you so I had to explain
to a friend of mine like the
significance of seeing an entirely Asian
cast like being represented I'm Filipino
so to me this we talked a lot about how
the Joy Luck Club was the last time that
this happened and when I explain it to
them like growing up not seeing yourself
in any leading role ever they kind of
like them I kind of blew up right have
you had to have that conversation with
people in your life you know I I had
that conversation with myself I mean the
the issue of representation is that you
don't realize how powerful it is until
you see it and you don't realize how
much of a privilege it is I never I grew
up maybe questioning or kind of knowing
that like there was a lack in the media
but you know when you're when you're
used to that it's kind
the way it is yeah we're crazy rotations
it's such a powerful experience for so
many people I see these these young
asian asian kids and they're walking out
and they're crying and and I I want them
to be spoiled with representation I want
them you know later on I want kids to
feel that 25 years like I was crazy
how's that possible
and I don't want it to be the last I
want it to be the first of many yeah I
mean there's a kind of a danger that
this is a moment in time in terms of
representation like that we're
celebrating this year and patting
themselves on the back and then things
will kind of go back to normal do you
think that that could potentially be the
case or do you really think this is a
moment of change for the future I'm very
optimistic about the future but I also
you know I am wary about you know when
representation becomes a trend you know
that's what people are talking about you
don't want to be a representation of me
in you know but you know my experience
as an actress it hasn't not been long
and I've had the privilege of working
with a lot of actors have been innocent
for a long time and they really feel the
difference and and even the roles that
I've been getting sent in the past two
years there's so much more substantial
there's so much more open you know and
and so I only feel optimistic about the
other future yeah your experience in
oceans eight must have been something
that was kind of next-level working with
all those people are you guys is there
plans on the second one are you guys
moving in - no I I don't know but you
know what I'm available I am available
call me call me 555 whatever the rest
yeah I mean I don't know but I just feel
so lucky that I've been a part of kind
of these movies that have done so well I
guess and and and are different and and
celebrate difference and yeah hopefully
fingers crossed you know keep keep on
going awesome hey thanks for your time